you
[Music]
[Applause]
good afternoon everyone you're probably
wondering what does it mean when I speak
about the Herodian mind now and we're
living in very very strange times and
the times we are living in not only
affect us but affect the entire world
and before they killed Tyndall he had
one last prayer and he said Lord open
the eyes of the king of England and so
before I start this lecture not that I
want to be in Tyndall's character in
shoes but before I start this lecture I
also would like to pray and ask the Lord
for a special favour
so if you will allow me Heavenly Father
throughout the ages you have wanted the
eyes of those that do not see to be
opened and today I want to pray that you
will open the eyes of your church and
that you will not only open the eyes of
your church but that you will open the
eyes of the whole world so that the
gathering may commence this is my prayer
in Jesus name Amen now that might seem
like a somewhat strange preamble to some
but in today's world and in today's
climate of cooperation and ecumenism it
is not politically correct to speak
about the issues pertaining to the three
angels messages and this is causing
quite some consternation there are even
some who believe that prophecy being
conditional the issues regarding the
Antichrist and what the reformers
believed regarding the papal system that
that doesn't apply because it could be a
conditional prophecy and it might never
happen perhaps it only has an
eschatological future but not for the
here and now so today we can be in a
commanding all sessions of whatever
guest saw as observers but it doesn't
really pertain to us they are some to
say that say we should not preach on the
issue of the Antichrist and the three
angels messages in the way that we do
because it is offensive
we should have other ways of preaching
this issue and some will say it's not
part about 28 fundamental beliefs and if
you've studied them carefully it doesn't
say so it says that the Reformers
believe that the papal system was
Antichrist but it doesn't
mentally say we still believe it
although it is there of course in the
spirit of prophecy but if you say that
the spirit of prophecy cannot be used in
that sense well then you don't really
have a leg to stand on then it opens the
floodgates and anything can come into
the church and so today when you start
speaking on these issues and you link
history and you link current events to
the prophecies they have a nice
catchphrase for it and it's called
conspiracy theories have you heard that
yes it's called conspiracy theories and
some will warn and say that we shouldn't
be associated in any way with these
conspiracy theories now I don't deny the
fact that there are conspiracy theories
out there but I do deny the fact that a
clear exegesis of the Bible linked to
current events is not conspiracy but
fulfillment of prophecy and so this is
quite a problem to me and when some of
our leading men write that we should not
look at current events and watch the
news to see what is happening because
then we are inclined towards these
conspiracy theories and please do not
support anyone that does this kind of
thing or when even leaders start
discussing this issue and saying that
those who propagate any such ideas
should really not be tolerated then it
is time to take a deeper look and so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
speak about the issue first in the
philosophical sense and see where it
leads and then hopefully we can come to
some kind of conclusion as to where we
are in the stream of time and where it
fits into
see if some would want to call this
conspiracy that they may if some of them
would rather see it as a confederacy
then they may - I see it as a
fulfillment of prophecy and I see it as
a fulfillment of the Word of God and I
can see that we are heading towards the
very final events on this planet a
testimonies there is a study of history
that is not to be condemned
sacred history was one of the studies in
the school of the prophets in the record
of his dealings with the nations were
traced the footsteps of Jehovah so today
we ought to consider the dealings of God
with the nations of the earth we are to
see in history the fulfillment of
prophecy to study the workings of
Providence in the great Reformatory
movements and to understand the progress
of events in the marshalling of the
nations for the final conflict for the
growth of the great controversy that's a
commission and that is a commission
which is in direct contradiction to the
sentiments that I have just spoken about
we have an injunction if we are Watchmen
on the walls of Zion to watch the events
of history and to fit them into
prophetic pictures or else we could just
miss the bus I wouldn't like anyone to
miss the bus and particularly my church
I fear for my church when they
marginalize the third angels message and
the second angels message let us go back
in history this is the god Marduk and he
had a sign which was the sign of an O he
also has a sword and the
has a trident - trident in fact here
which are in actual fact Thunderbolts
you will find this deity as you go
through the various cultures in many
many forms you will find the deities
throwing their thunder bolts from the
seus of the Greeks all the way through
the the cultures of the world now many
of these legends have their origin in
some reality and the origin goes back
all the way to the very beginning you
see the god Marduk was the son of Anu
and he had the commission he received
the Commission to rule over evil so the
earth and the creation and everything
that was here was evil
and he received authority from God to
rule over the darkness and the evil and
his sign is embroidered here on the hem
of his coat and upon his arm he has the
mark of authority to rule over the
powers of evil now if you go back into
history some will claim that this is
actually a reference all the way back to
the beginning and the story of Cain and
Abel here is the God shamash and here he
has the symbol of a new this eight
pointed star which was two crosses as it
were the wavy line represents the female
and the straight lines represents the
male principle because these deities
were always in console they were male
and they were female
now Ishtar was the Queen of the Night
as she is called in the British Museum
and she also had a star and as you can
it is the same symbol it is the sign of
Anna and she also ruled the night and
you find her in all the different
cultures when you go to Egypt it will be
Isis and Horus the Sun and Osiris the
father who then became reborn as the Sun
so these were the deities that ruled
over evil and had the authority from the
Creator God to rule over the children of
Idul and so they have probably got their
origin in a greater reality now when you
look at the laws and the structures that
they evolved to rule over people and we
find some interesting facts here this is
one of the earliest laws known the Code
of Hammurabi it is well preserved the
Babylonian law code and it dates back to
177 to BC it's one of the oldest
deciphered writings of significant
length in the world is the sixth
Babylonian king Hammurabi and act at the
code in partial copies exist on a
human-sized stone Stella in various clay
tablets
now the code consists of 282 laws with
scaled punishments adjusting an eye for
an eye a tooth for a tooth as graded
depending on social status slave versus
free man nearly one half of the code
deals with matters of contract
establishing for example the wages to be
paid to an ox driver or a surgeon so
these are laws of government do they
remind you of laws today do we have laws
governing all these things coming into
existence in the world all over big
statute books of law so they dealt with
many many things so they dealt with
economic measures they dealt with labor
questions they dealt with the penal
punishments for various crimes other
set the terms of the transaction
establishing reliability of the Builder
for a house that collapses to have laws
like that today for example or property
that is damaged while left in the care
of another do we have laws like that
today
a third of the code addresses issues
concerning household and family
relationships such as inheritance
divorce paternity sexual behavior do we
have laws like that today only one
provision appears to impose obligations
on an official this provision
establishes that a judge who reaches an
incorrect decision is to be fined and
removed from the bench permanently a
handful of provisions address issues
related to military service and then it
is signed with the following on this on
the stellar it says a new and Bell
called by my call by name me Hammurabi
the exalted prince who feared Marduk the
chief god of to bring about the rule in
the land so they had the power to rule
they had their capacity to rule from the
highest authority who they said was God
God gave them the power to rule now if
we go to Bible Commentary we'll see that
the code of hammurabi rob Hammurabi was
one of the oldest collections of laws
but there were others as well that were
older than that it was written in
Sumerian this one and then it was
discovered near Baghdad and then the
code of King Palama of Asuna who ruled
some 300 years before Hammurabi was
found and then another law was found
that of all namu and it's fascinating
that the further you go back in history
the more similarity there is between
God's law and the laws of the nation so
as people moved away further and further
from allegiance to God's law the laws
became more and more and more intrusive
and more complex but these people who
had these laws ruled with an iron fist
over the people of the earth authorized
by God as I attempt the 14 verse 13 and
I has said in my heart I will ascend
into heaven I will exalt my throne above
the stars I will sit also upon the Mount
of the congregation in the sides of the
north so let's go back to the earliest
times here was a power in heaven Lucifer
and he wanted to be in charge he wanted
to sit in the seat that God occupied
hard Mountain that means a kingdom the
parallel in the Bible so he wanted to
sit upon the kingdom of God as it were
and he wanted to be part of this
congregation so by implication and
assembly the congregation a place of
meeting or a signal appointed place
assembly feast seasons solemn synagogue
he wanted to rule over the people he
wanted to have rulership where we know
what happened to him there was a war in
heaven Michael and his angels fought
against the Dragon and the dragon fought
and his angels and they were cast out
and then he came down to this earth and
there was Adam a knee and then he worked
on their minds and he deceived them and
he became the ruler of this planet but
God had a way out and God devised the
plan of salvation and in Genesis chapter
3:15 we read and I will put enmity
between thee and the woman between thy
see
and her seed it shall bruise thy head
and thou shalt bruise his heel and James
for verse 4 it says ye adulterers and
adulteresses know ye not that the
friendship of the world is enmity with
God whosoever therefore will be a friend
of the world is the enemy of God so we
have two groups we have the world and we
have God's people do God's people have a
law yes God's people have a law and it's
the law
as we find it in the Bible which defines
character the Ten Commandments and is
there a war between good and evil
yes it's called enmity between thee and
the woman God's people those who belong
to God's church the woman so they are
subject to a law they have a covenant
with God but they are not taken out of
this world they are part of this world
and they are living in a world that is
ruled not everywhere or hardly any place
by God's people is that right so the
others are ruling with what authority
are they ruling and how are they ruling
we'll have to look into that issue but
the fact of the matter is that what the
world does and how the world thinks
should be opposite to what God's people
do and think now many of the laws of the
land are of course the same as those
that God's people would keep for example
thou shalt not kill thou shalt not steal
and all of these and as well as the law
doesn't interfere with God's law God
says you must have pay the public
authorities so you must be part of the
system without becoming engrossed in
this
them now we read that this declaration I
will put enmity was not only a
declaration of war but it was the first
gospel preached the first gospel sermon
ever preached to fallen man this promise
was the star about illuminating the dark
and dismal future of the race
Adam gladly received the welcome
assurance of deliverance and diligently
instructed his children in the way of
the Lord so here was a chance a way out
structure children the promise was
presented in close connection with the
altar of the sacrificial offering you
cannot separate the two salvation always
lies outside of ourselves it is in
Christ the altar and the promise stands
side by side and one cast clear beams of
light upon the other showing that the
Justice of an offended God could be
appeased only by the death of his
beloved son so if you are in Christ you
are linked to the sacrifice in the case
of Cain and Abel we have a type of two
classes that will exist in the world
till the close of time and this type is
worthy of close study so this is strike
two we have to study history we have to
study the dealings of God with the
nations we have to study the
Providence's of God in current times and
apply them to what God has promised
would happen that's prophecy and we are
to study these two arch types it's part
of our job description Cain represents
those who carry out the principles and
works of Satan but I worshiping God in a
way of their own choosing it doesn't say
they don't worship God
it says they worship God in a way of
their own choosing this is very
important
so you can have godly people or parent
godly people out there but they are
worshipping God in a way of their own
choosing and not in a way that God said
he should be worship and we need to be
very clear about this distinction like
the leader whom they follow they are
willing to render partial obedience but
not entire submission to God the Cain
class of worshipers includes by far the
largest number so anywhere you go God's
people will be outnumbered is that a
fact
and so we are outnumbered and yet we are
not taken out of the world we are in the
world but shouldn't be part of the world
for every false religion that has been
invented has been based on the Cain
principle every false religion that has
ever been invented is based on the Cain
religion now just help me here to the
law and the testimony if they speak not
according to this word they have no
light in them
should it be difficult to determine
which religion is based on the Cain
principle and which religion is based on
the God principle don't we have a guide
whereby to determine this now don't get
me wrong if the vast majority of mankind
belongs to the worship of the Cain
principle does that mean we isolate
ourselves from this group and have
nothing to do with them well then I
would still be part of the King
principle wouldn't I because I came out
of the world and so would most of you be
part of the Cain principle isn't that
correct
so we don't want to be part of the kind
principal and God in His mercy makes a
way of escape for everyone who's part of
the gang principle so you never write
them off but you may never ever forget
whose principle you fall under okay so
every false religion that has been
invented has been based on the Kane
principle that man can depend upon his
own merits and righteousness for
salvation every false religion Genesis
chapter 4 verse 8 and Cain talked with
Abel his brother because his sacrifice
wasn't accepted he brought the fruits of
his labor and said there it is now had
God instructed them on the plan of
salvation absolutely the very clothes
they're wearing skins in this picture
tells you that God instructed them the
lamb had already pointed ahead to the
coming of the Lamb of God and they must
have been instructed that without the
shedding of blood there will be no
remission of sins pointing to the Lamb
of God
so here Cain and Abel are bringing their
various offerings the one according to
the dictates of God the other one
according to his own dictates and when
it happened that he wasn't accepted
Cain's when they were in the field that
Cain rose up against Abel his brother
and slew him
now there are some I'm not too averse to
the idea that think well maybe Cain even
justified his act maybe they thought
that one of them would be blood
sacrifice maybe he slew him even
thinking well if God if you want a blood
sacrifice why take a lamb why not give
you the real thing so it doesn't seem as
though he had great repentance he had
sorrow for what he had lost but not
sorrow for what he had done is that
correct I'm not saying it was so it was
probably a fit of rage but in some way
he must have justified it and God came
to him and said what hast thou done the
voice of thy brother's blood cries unto
me from the ground and now art thou
cursed from the earth and has opened her
mouth to receive thy brother's blood
from thy hand and when thou tillest the
ground it shall not henceforth yield
unto her a strength a fugitive and a
vagabond shalt thou be on the earth and
Cain said unto the Lord my punishment is
greater than I can bear
is there any sorrow in there no he has a
problem with the punishment he doesn't
necessarily have a problem with what he
did behold thou has driven me out this
day from the face of the earth and from
thy faith shall I be hid and I shall be
a fugitive and a vagabond in the earth
and it shall come to pass that everyone
that findeth me shall slay me and now an
outcast what am I going to do now God in
his foresight sees that the children of
disobedience are going to eventually be
far more than the children of obedience
isn't that right and somebody has to
rule and if he puts the minority in
charge of the majority eventually all
the Able's that are there will be slain
is that a possibility and so God has to
find the solution who's going to rule
over the children of evil who's going to
do it
they will slay me and so God makes a
covenant with Cain and the Lord said
unto him therefore whosoever slayeth
Cain vengeance shall be taken on him
Sevenfold and the Lord set a mark upon
Cain lest any finding him should kill
him now there's been a lot of
speculation as to what the Mark of Cain
is but we only have to look at the words
to get an idea as to what the Mark of
Cain is
the mark the word is interesting because
it's the Hebrew oath if you would take
it straight into the English it would be
oats but of course we're not going to do
that
lest we get theologically slaughtered
we'll just say that the Hebrew is oath
which means a signal as a flag a beacon
a monument a prodigy an evidence a mock
sign a token now I forgot exodus 31:13
where we're talking about the children
of God it says speak that also unto the
children of Israel saying verily my
Sabbath you shall keep for it is a sign
and the word there is Oh same word
exactly the same word between me and you
throughout your generations that you may
know that I am the lord that does
sanctify you two signs one the Mark of
Cain the other one the mark of God's
people the mark of God
the Sabbath tells you where you come
from and the Sabbath tells you in
Deuteronomy that you are redeemed you
have been bought with a price so here
are God's people they have the oath of
God they are keeping the commandments of
God they are in the minority when Cain
sent one of Adams rebellious daughters
sided with him I'm speculating of course
and decided that she was more affiliated
to him then to the others and went with
him if he goes I go he must have gotten
a wife somewhere right and so the family
split up doesn't say so in the Bible but
it's a logical deduction and those that
fell under the rule of Cain received the
Mark of Cain and those that fell under
the rule of God had a simple sign of
obedience to God's commandments right
from the very beginning and I think that
that is a logical conclusions of the
mark is not some physical stamp or sign
that he had it is a mark of authority
because the Sabbath is a sign of
authority
therefore the Mark of Cain must be a
sign of authority
this one acknowledging the authority of
God and this one are not acknowledging
no higher authority than himself so it's
to authorities the one full subject to
God the other one full subject to the
Mark of Cain so they will set the
authority they will set the tone and
vengeance shall be taken on him
Sevenfold don't mess with Cain if Cain
as you in a transgression against him
he'll punish you seven times he has the
authority don't mess with him and Cain
knew his wife and she conceived and bare
Enoch and he builded a city and called
the name of the city after the name of
his son Enoch so now the children of
disobedience start growing and I'm sure
there were other defectors along the
line and Cain's family grew much faster
than that of the Lord's people Adam and
Eve tried their best to stem the tide
so this firstborn of Cain his name was
you know not to be confused with the
other you know because this one didn't
walk with God this one started to build
cities and until you know who was born a
rat in the rat began may well yell and
may weigh on me to Zion and Methuselah
beget Lamech and the rod sets in and
Lamech took unto Him two wives so now we
have apostasy increasing the name of the
one was Adah and the name of the other
Zillah and then it gets even worse was
23 and Lamech said unto his wives Adah
and Zillah hear my voice ye wives of
Lamech hearken unto my speech for I have
slain a man
here's another murderer in the line of
Cain but he is an inheritor of the
authority because this is going down the
sons of Cain to my wounding and a young
man to my hurt if Cain shall be Avenged
Sevenfold truly Lamech seventy and
Sevenfold so the rules will get tougher
but not only that I was interested in
the seventy and Sevenfold and I looked
for a translation because it's hard to
determine what it is
I like the Geneva Bible and as you know
that is the old Bible so the spelling
looks funny but if Cain shall be in the
old days that was one word if Cain shall
be Avenged Sevenfold truly Lamech
seventy times seven fold says the Geneva
Bible I like that seventy times seven
does that ring a bell it rings a bell
somewhere Oh what happened at the end of
the seventy times seven that you find in
the Book of Daniel probation closed for
the Jews as a nation not as individuals
but as a nation
so if Cain was to have a Sevenfold
structure then Lama would have a seventy
times seven structure but it would only
last until God said probation for you is
closed does that make sense I'm
speculating it's a conspiracy but it
does does seem that these words are not
just arbitrary now let's jump straight
into the esoteric world and let me just
make plain again that my sources will be
the very best sources for those who want
to make them obscure I will quote from
the highest occult sources in the world
and I will quote from encyclicals
directly from the Vatican so that
anybody who wishes to say that these are
not authoritative had better check them
out and see whether it is so morals and
dogma Albert Pike you know what's
fascinating is that the esoteric world
doesn't deny the Bible it just twists
the Bible it doesn't deny the chronology
of the Bible
the evolutionists deny the chronology of
the Bible
these are tarik world knows that the
Bible is true that's fascinating
now Mars and dogma Albert Pike he says
the following you know his name
signified in the Hebrew initiate or
initiate or so he's the initiative of
the initiator the legend of the columns
of granite and brass or bronze erected
by him is probably symbolic oh he's the
one who built the city remember that of
bronze which survived the flood is
supposed to symbolize the mysteries of
which masonry is the legitimate
successor so irrespective of the stuff
in between those two points there we can
say according to the occult world
Enoch is the initiate and the initiate
talk and Freemasonry is the inheritor of
whatever it is that was initiated is
that correct
so we're saying good so masonry traces
its origin back to in all high masonry
from the earliest times the custodian or
masonry is the legitimate successor of
the Enoch principle from the earliest
times the custodian and depository of
the great philosophical and religious
truths unlearned to the world at large
unknown to the world at large and handed
down from age to age by an unbroken
current of tradition do we have a
religious organization that prides
itself on its tradition embodied in
symbols emblems and allegories so they
trace themselves back from Enoch and
then they say Enoch walked with God and
all these marvelous things but don't
believe everything these people say
check it out do a careful
so which enough are they talking about
are they talking about the enough that
walked with God or are they talking
about the ena the son of Kane well we
can find out enough son of Jared
descended from Abe Adam via the line of
said so it's a different line and he is
called in the Bible the seventh
generation from Adam and if we use the
chronology from Asha that even the
spirit of prophecy used then inna would
have been born in the three three eight
two BC that's now the Enoch that walked
with God Pike's book is dated Masonic
Lee and it's dated by Christian
reckoning this is fascinating stuff it
has two dates one is the Masonic date
and one is the Christian date and the
reckoning in pikes book to enoch is
given as the year five 860 a.m. and if
you look that up it means unknown Mundi
the year of the world so when did the
world as we know it begin and when did
this unbroken line of succession come
down the line of history all the way to
modern Freemasonry
according to Pike it all started in the
year five 860 an or Mundi you're of the
world but it also has the normal date in
it and it says the book came was written
in 1871 ad all right so if I want to
find out if five 860 anno Mundi is the
same as 1870 ad then when was it BC well
then you have to subtract the one from
the other five at 60 minus 1871 to get
the BC date from an ad date you get to
the three-eighths
0-9 BC so the masonic calendar starts in
3 809 bc and that is 427 years before
the Enoch that walked with God so the
dates and the very high occult writings
tell us that the Enoch that they
referred to is which one the inner of K
so this unbroken line of authority comes
all the way from Cain now let's read the
secret doctrine by Blavatsky because in
the ISA Tirek world everything is turned
round good becomes evil and evil becomes
good let's just check this out once more
once that the key to Genesis is in our
hands
it is the scientific symbolical Kabbalah
which unveils the secret the great
serpent of the Garden of Eden and the
Lord God are identical and so are
Jehovah and Cain what so Cain is the god
of this world who gave his power to rule
to his son and he dedicated the city to
him and he said there now a city also
stands for a government doesn't it isn't
Babylon called the city yes or no so
Babylon is called a city and Enoch got
the power to rule over the city and the
Lord God is the same as Cain then it
means that Cain gave his power to rule
to his son Enoch and the Mark of Cain
was transferred the power and authority
to rule was transferred from Cain to ena
and then in an unbroken line all the way
through to the modern world according to
them that Cain who is referred to in
theology as the murderer and a liar to
God
chav attempts the king of Israel to
number the people and Satan tempts him
to do the same in another place Java
turns into the fiery serpent to bite
those he's displeased with and Jehovah
informs the brazen serpent that heals
them these short and seemingly
contradictory statements in the Old
Testament contradictory because the two
powers are separated instead of being
regarded as the two faces of one and the
same thing or the secret doctrine so
good is evil evil is good the Lord God
is really okay so in that sense I knew
would be Cain he is also the son of Gaea
the moon goddess fascinating eeeh Eve
and so there's an element of truth in
these old legends the Appalachians Satan
in Hebrews sat on an adversary from the
word shaitana to be adverse belongs by
right to the first and cruelest
adversary of all the other gods jehovah
this is the secret doctrine not to the
serpent who spoke only words of sympathy
and wisdom and is the worst even in the
dogma of the adversary of men so the
enemies who the enemies God so in the
line of Cain the true God is the enemy
in the line of Cain the true God is the
enemy and if there is a godly person
like Abel if it is within his power what
will he do to him he'll kill him he'll
kill him
that's his mindset he wants to rule he
has the power to rule he has an
authority to rule he can punish
Sevenfold seventy times seven fault he
can put you into jail and into misery
for whatever and keep you there and tell
you rights he has the power to do it and
he hates the God of heaven
that's his mindset now deception of
course is something that comes into play
as well because many who are subject to
the rule
of the cane stream don't even know that
they are part of the cane stream and so
they are deceived into following this
rule whether they like it or not
therefore jehovah was called by the
Gnostics the creator of and one with a
few mortals the serpent of Satan so you
have a reversal a gospel reversal
Genesis chapter 6 verse 1 now evil
starts increasing on this planet Cain
rules with ruthlessness through his line
and by the time you get to LA me it is
chaos and oppressive power you mess with
me and my authority I will sort you out
and it came to pass when men began to
multiply on the face of the earth and
the daughters were born unto them that
the sons of God saw that the daughters
of men that they were fair and they took
them wives of all which they chose so as
I've said before God's beautiful
children go to do shopping in the mall
and there they see the daughters of men
with their short little skirts and their
tantalizing little ways and before you
know it they intermarry and the Lord
says he will not strive with them
forever your time shall be one hundred
and twenty years and they were giants
nepheline apostates not angelic people
that's wishful thinking on their part
no there were apostates Nephilim on the
earth in those days and also after that
when the sons of God the line of the
children of Adam through the line of
Seth came unto the daughters of men and
bear children to them the same became
mighty men which were of old men of
now so you had men who received great
honor in the media when you looked at
the television set the antediluvian set
you saw all the men of great valor and
all the rulers and they were the great
philanthropists of the world the
powerful rulers the presidents the ones
who were making the speeches and God saw
that the wickedness of man was great in
the earth and that every imagination of
the thoughts of his heart was only evil
continually and it repented the Lord
that he had made man on the earth and it
grieved him at his heart and so in the
seventy times seven was full he said
probation for the antediluvian world is
over and he destroys them except one
family of course Noah's family was all
perfect right no I think there might
have been some daughters there that were
married to them who knows whether there
were daughters of men or daughters of
God and perhaps the line of Cain came
along with the ship and the theology of
Cain was in the ship God is gracious
isn't he God is gracious do we have a
parallel anywhere else Sodom and
Gomorrah were they all perfect that was
saved there or do we have Moabites and
MMA ammonites as a consequence so the
post-flood apostasy and the rule of Cain
resumed then through the lineage of ham
so the line wasn't actually broken the
apostasy the great oppression the great
evil was arrested for a while but it
didn't take long before it flourished on
the planet again and finally we come to
the descendants of ham and we come to
Nimrod and Flavius Josephus writes of
Cephas writes of Nimrod now it was
Nimrod who excited them to set
a friend and contempt of God he was the
grandson of one of NOAA's most wicked
son ham therefore great-grandson of Noah
a bold man of great strength of hand he
persuaded his people not to ascribe
their joys to God as if it were through
his means they were happy but to believe
that it was their own courage which
procured that happiness do we have that
same philosophy today he also gradually
changed the government into a tyranny he
had the same mindset he had the same
mindset
seeing no other way of turning men from
the fear of God but to bring them in
constant dependence on his power he also
said he would be revenged on God if he
should have a mind to drown the world
again and for that he would pull the
tower too high for the waters to reach
and that he would avenge himself on God
for destroying their forefathers enmity
towards God enmity - it's anyone who
opposes him in this issue and he begins
to rule he is the legitimate heir then
of the power to rule over the children
of evil
well masonry actually in its writing
says that the Tower of Babel was their
enterprise
so if morals and dogma traces it back to
Enoch then other writers trace it back
to Nimrod but it's the same thing the
one just takes the post-flood
reoccurrence and the other one takes it
from the pre-flood and so the Tower of
Babel is depicted as a Masonic
Enterprise Arthur it would wait as
regards masonry Babel of course
represented them a sonic Enterprise it
is well known that the Tower of Babel is
one of the most ancient traditions of
masonry so they don't make any bones
about it and the masonic quiz book the
question is asked who was number odd the
answer was he was the son of cush and
the old constitution referred to as one
of the founders of masonry and in the
scripture as the architect of many
cities was in a her architect of cities
so here you have city dwellers and
country mouse all right we filed at the
making of the Tower of Babel there was
masonry first much esteemed of and
Nimrod was a Mason himself and loved
well Mason's these are Masonic sources
now as we go down through history we
come to the various ruling powers the
super powers of Earth that held sway and
we will find some parallels in all of
them they all received the same power to
rule over the children of disobedience
those who chose their own way to worship
God if we go down in time to the history
to the history of the Egyptians taught
Moses the third he's the one who said
who is the Lord that I should obey his
voice he was the Napoleon of Egypt he
was the great lawmaker nobody stood in
his way or he would destroy them and he
made 90 Sabbath laws you will remember
when he said you will not rest you will
not Shabbat you will not keep the
Sabbath you will not rest but you will
get unto your burdens and when he made
laws which counted God's law his
authority was judged at an end by God so
who permitted him to rule until he
overstepped the mark God God permitted
him to rule did God permit the king of
Egypt to even be the authority in terms
of government procedures of his own
children yes or no yes where they
subject to the rules of Egypt yes did he
have the power to even enslave them yes
or no yes did he had the power to
oppress them the Bible says they were
solely oppressed but there was a limit
seventy times seven when your probation
clothes closes you will be eradicated so
let's go away from Egypt and let's go to
the Assyrians
this is history grisly Assyrian record
of torture and death a Syrian national
history as it has been preserved for us
in the inscriptions and pictures
consists almost solely of military
campaigns and battles when you look at
the news today do you see military
campaigns and battles yes or no so it
seems as if the this line of power that
rules over the children of disobedience
has military might and military power
and exercises that power even over the
children of God is that right
a theory emerged as a territorial state
in the 14th century BC its territory
covered approximately the northern part
of modern Iraq the first capital of
Assyria was 'soul located about 150
miles north of the modern Baghdad and
there on the left is a relief of a
Syrian torturer they would rip the skins
of people off their bodies while they
were alive the Bible tells us that they
took Manasseh with hawks through his
nose and dragged him to Babylon he must
have had one painful nose on the west
coast of the Tigris River the city was
named for its national God a soul from
which the name Assyria is also derived
from the outside this area projected
itself as a strong military power bent
on conquest countries and people that
oppose such Syrian rule were punished by
the destruction of their cities and the
devastation of their fields and orchards
in the 9th century Assyria had
consolidated hit hit Emir over the
northern Mesopotamia it was then that
the Assyrian armies marched beyond their
own borders to expand their empires
seeking booty
financed their plans for storm or
conquest and power by the mid 19th
century the Syrian Menace posed the
direct threat to the small sir of Cairo
Palestine states to the West including
Israel and Judah so do they eventually
try to take over God's people as well
yes and they have the line of authority
because there are children of
disobedience and these are reliefs where
we find the Assyrian armies here are the
heads of the decapitated people that
they decapitate it here they are the
people are strung up on poles with
Spears all the way through them the
cruelest tortures that you can imagine
and people were scared of these rulers
if Cain shall be Avenged 7 times Lamech
seventy times seven times if you don't
fall subject to us we'll show you what
power we have and we have authority we
have it directly by permission of God
it's got to Roman law by this time the
governments of the world have
consolidated a legal system which is
second to none there's a law for every
single transgression you can think of
there are penalties for moral deeds
which are just indescribable and
permissions for immorality which are
equally indescribable
does it bring about and how did they
deal with the centers in the Roman
Empire well you were thrown to the Lions
in the Coliseum you were crucified on a
cross you were eaten alive by animals
you were whipped with whips until your
entrails hung out the cruelty was just
in discs
and their aggression did their
aggression turn against God's people yes
or no yes it did but they ruled and they
had power to rule now let's have a look
at one man who lived at that time and
his name was Herod the Great he has been
described as a madman who murdered his
own family and a great many rabbis if he
murdered a great many rabbis then did he
have power to do so even over God's
people yes or no master that the evil
genius of the Judean nation prepared to
commit any crime in order to gratify his
unbounded Abyss ambition any crime and
the greatest bull day in Jewish history
is known for his colossal building
projects there's this ring a bell you
know does this ring a bell
Nimrod the great builders so they love
their cities they love their great
monumental buildings
he's now info colossal building projects
out Judea including his expansion of the
Second Temple in Jerusalem now excuse me
this man is a cruel cruel ruler who has
power to rule God's people are even
subject to him and he's building a
temple for the worship of Yahweh the
construction of the port at Samaria and
Masada and rhodium and all of these and
he was a powerful man the Aronian
dynasty was a Judean dynasty of Edomite
itta men descent a Rodian dynasty began
with Herod the Great to assume the
throne of Judea so he ruled over God's
people with Roman support and bringing
down the century-long Hasmonean Kingdom
his kingdom lasted until his death in
four pce
when it was divided between his sons as
Tetrarchy which lasted about ten years
most of those kingdoms including Judea
were incorporated into the provinces etc
etc these Judaizers were not
considered jewish by the dominant
pharaoh sake of tradition so even though
Herod may have considered himself of the
Jewish faith he was not considered
Jewish by the observant and national
Jews of Judea could we say today that
there are some people who consider
themselves of the Christian faith for
those who believe in the law of God and
the Torah do not really consider them of
the same level of knowledge in terms of
Christianity yes or no they're possible
now Aaron was a loyal supporter of
Haqqanis to Auntie Potter appointed
Herod governor of Galilee at twenty-five
in his elder brother governor of
Jerusalem and he enjoyed the backing of
Rome but his brutality was condemned by
the son Hedren he was brutal he was a
ruthless room man two years later an
taganas nephew took the throne from his
uncle with the help of the Parthian san
Herod fled to Rome and they did some
pleading with his Roman rulers to
restore him to power and there he was
elected by the Roman Senate King of the
Jews now here was a king of the Jews and
Josephus and the encyclopedias or the
sources and Romans 913 says as it is
written Jacob I loved but Esau I have
hated now does God hate people of course
not
so what did God hate he hated the
mindset of you know he hated the mindset
of you know and here was a man who
claimed to be ruler over God's people
but he had the mindset of you know and
God
that mindset did God permit him to rule
yes he permitted him to rule his first
leadership role was as governor of
Galilee a position granted to him by his
father and dupatta early on Herod
demonstrate his brutality by ruthlessly
crushing a revolt in Galilee later
during the Parthian incursion he flees
makes his way to Rome where impresses
Marc Anthony and with his help persuades
the Roman senators to name him King of
the Jews
say can return and bring Judea back
under Roman control and after three
years of fighting he takes the throne
and he is officially King of the Jews
can you see why is upset when suddenly
there's a rumor there's another King of
the Jews Matthew to verse 18 in Ramah
there was a voice heard lamentation and
weeping and great mourning Rachel
weeping for her children and would not
be comforted for they are not so he
murders the little children in order to
get rid of Christ but he underestimates
God does he persecute God's people yes
does he hate this kind of opposition
godly opposition absolutely
whose mindset does he have he has the
mindset of Cain he has the mindset of
Cain he has the same power to rule who
does he get his power from who Glens him
that power gives him his title roh-roh
gave him his power gave him his title
you're the king of the Jews and so he
built the temple I'm the king of the
Jews I'll build a temple and he builds a
temple but here it's all fit however to
place at the main entrance a huge Roman
Eagle who does he dedicate the temple to
not to the God of the universe he
dedicates the temple which stands for
worship he did
- wrong this is history and the pious
Jews saw this as sacrilege as well they
should here it was in symbols take it in
antitype can we see God's worship
dedicated to Rome today yes or no
wouldn't the pious Christians see that
as sacrilege yes or no okay two teachers
and a group of tourists students smashed
this emblem of idolatry and oppression
but Herod had them hunted down and
dragged in Chains to his residence in
Jericho where they were burned alive do
you see his mindset do you know of
Christians that were later burned alive
because they had a different mindset -
ROH thus having built the temple Herod
took pains to make sure it would be run
without future problems of this kind you
will worship your God according to my
dictates he pointed his own high priests
having by then put to death 46 leading
members of the Sanhedrin the rabbinical
court so by the time Jesus actually
starts preaching the good guys old dead
already
have been put to sleep Herod's cruelty
was legendary I'm talking about the
Herodian mind but it's not isolated to
Herod it is a historic mindset that
comes all the way from the Garden of
Eden and runs with an unbroken chain all
the way through history and to our
present day and we have to find the
current custodians of this here Odeon
mindset now I chose Herod I could have
said the mind of Cain but I find the
inherent the culmination
of history because it is Herod or his
son who was also a Herod who even
crucified the Prince of Peace
so this mind said this enmity towards
God's people coupled with the power to
exercise it under official Authority is
mind-boggling because initially God
granted Cain the Mark of Cain the
authority to rule and he established an
enormous secret police force I want you
to look at history and let the bells
start ringing brutally killed anyone
suspected of plotting against him and
created Roman peace by slaughtering all
dissidents we will have military
intervention if you don't do as we say
Herod Antipas the mindset continues
remember the story of Herod Herod yes
and salamé
I don't want to go into that typology
I've done it before but the head of john
the baptist's give it to me now
fortunately in our typology this was a
type of the elijah but there was also an
elijah that was translated without
seeing death so we will see some of us
might end up being John the Baptist's
typologically and some of us might end
up hopefully being the other one the one
who did not see death and this is Jesus
before Herod Antipas can you imagine the
king and the Prince of the universe
being arrayed before this earthly
monarch who is sitting there by whose
authority
God's Authority he has been permitted to
rule because God in His mercy doesn't
want anyone to be lost
now when to ask your question did God
give Herod Antipas every single possible
opportunity to repent yes or no what
does that tell you about the character
of God
it's unbelievable unbelievable and I
want you to cast your mind back in
history the Babylonian Empire when
Nebuchadnezzar set up a system which was
just the same as Herod's Nebuchadnezzar
had a secret police second to none he
knew everything that was happening in
his kingdom he was unbelievably cruel if
you crossed him you ended up in the
fiery furnace alive throw you in there I
don't care if my soldiers die in the
process there was a cruel man he set up
a counterfeit system of religion did God
give him every opportunity to repent yes
or no will he be in heaven yes there are
Syrians if you go down in history you
come to neni way
was there a ruler who repented at the
preaching of Jonah one of the cruelest
of all rulers thing his name was not
married three and all of a sudden all
history of his cruelty ceases and there
is no more war and total peace in his
kingdom does God care about these rulers
yes and here he is arrayed before him he
gets a final opportunity he sees the
Prince of Peace he sees those eyes he
sees them personally and he has him
mocked and they put a reed in his hand
and they put a crown of thorns on his
head
and they beat him over the head over and
over and over again and say prophesy who
beat you over the head this is the mind
of hero it is a mind that has separated
itself from God
but it has power to rule and the same
day Pilate and Herod were made friends
together poor before they were at enmity
between themselves if there is one thing
that unites even the warring factions of
the children of Cain it's a common enemy
and if that gun a common enemy is still
the Prince of peace always followers so
much the better because Cain slew Abel
and that animosity towards the truth is
part and parcel of those who have the
Mark of Cain all the way through
revelation 12:3 and they appeared
another wonder in heaven and behold a
great dragon having seven heads and ten
horns and ten Crown's upon his heads and
his tail drew a third part of the stars
of heaven and it costs them to the earth
and the dragon stood before the woman
which woman which was ready to be
delivered for to devour her child as
soon as it was born
Herod the first and she brought forth a
man child who was to rule all nations
with a rod of iron and a child was
caught up unto God and to his throne he
is the true ruler his law is a law of
justice and mercy the other ruler also
rules with a rod of iron but he rules
with a Mark of Cain and the kings of the
earth stood up and the rulers were
gathered together against the Lord
against his Christ acts 426 for the
truth against thy Holy Child Jesus whom
thou hast anointed both Herod and
Pontius Pilate with the Gentiles and the
people of Israel were gathered together
that's scary that's scary
my question is the following can this
Mark of Cain
E
progress to within God's people itself
men and brethren children of the stock
of Abram and whosoever among you fear of
God to you is the word of the salvation
sent for they that dwell at Jerusalem
and their rulers because they knew him
not nor yet the voices of the prophets
which are read every Sabbath day they
have fulfilled them in condemning him so
what is the criterion of these rulers
they knew it not and they didn't know
the prophecies either they didn't know
him and they didn't know the prophecies
should God's people know him and the
prophecies yes or no okay now about that
time Herod the King stretched forth his
hands to vex certain of the church he
wasn't satisfied with killing the Prince
of Peace and handing over handing him
over beaten to Pilate no no he stretched
his hand out towards the church because
the mindset of Cain is slay Abel and
when Peter was come to himself he said
now I know for a surety that the Lord
has sent his angel because he imprisoned
even Peter I jumped a few verses there
and delivered me out of the hand of
Herod and from all the expectation of
the people of the Jews will there be
persecution yes or no
who is our only deliverer and our only
hope in that persecution Jesus and I
want you to remember that because we're
going to go into very fine detail here
and we prayed that the eyes of this
church and of the world will be open and
upon a said day Herod arrayed in royal
apparel set upon his throne and made an
oration unto them and the people gave a
shout saying it is the voice of a god
not of a man who do we hear things like
that someone today just from that little
balcony opens his mouth and says cheap
they say well it's a voice of a god
and immediately the angel of the Lord
smote him because he gave not glory to
the Lord and he was eaten of worms and
gave up the ghost there comes a time
when the seventy times seven is up and
probation stops for the rulers who rule
under the power of the mark of authority
given by God to Cain to rule over the
children of evil I exhort therefore that
first of all supplications prayers
intercessions and giving of thanks be
made for all men for kings and for all
that are in authority do you understand
that verse a little bit better we must
pray that God will curtail them in their
animosity towards God's people so that
the work of God can continue that we may
lead a quiet and peaceable life in all
godliness and honesty for this is good
and acceptable in the sight of God our
Savior God has handed over the children
of evil to the rules of evil you know my
wife gave classes she was a
schoolteacher in a very very very
depressed unruly very disenfranchised
school and the children were incredibly
unruly and violent they had strangled a
teacher that had stabbed another teacher
the police were afraid to break up the
gang fights in the school and she taught
in that school now my wife is a timid
lady and her Authority counted for
nought and so one day she said to them
all right you don't want to listen to my
rules and you make the rules and I said
ok and I started making the rules if you
do this then that happens to you if you
do this and I met along
list of rules the most draconian rules
that you can imagine like if you chew
gum or something you will sweep the
whole school with a toothbrush on your
knees until the skin comes off rules
like that and they stuck to their rules
and there was harmony in the class so
when she couldn't rule over them she
handed them over to the Mark of Cain and
said rule over the children of evil and
they said we will increase the rules 712
nay seventy times seventy is that I
thought there is a good example and
that's exactly what God did he said okay
you don't want to accept my authority
I'll hand you over to that authority and
behind that authority stands another
authorities called the dragon and he's
blowing his evil breath upon them put
them in mind to be subject to
principalities and powers to obey
magistrates to be ready to every good
work to speak evil of no man to be no
brawlers but gentle showing or meekness
unto all men for rulers are not a terror
to good works but to evil will tell
their not be afraid of the power do that
which is good and thou shalt have praise
of the same and it works like that if
you do good people despise you but
eventually they sort of respect you
especially when you're dead isn't this a
yes go and look at the monuments of all
the great men that were hated and
respected after their death so that we
may boldly say the Lord is my helper and
I will not fear what man shall do unto
me so we are not in a perfect situation
God has given them the power to rule we
are subject to that rule just like the
children of Israel were subject to
Pharaoh there's nothing we can do about
it but we can pray we can pray for them
and we can obey the rules of the land as
far as they do not come into conflict
with God's law and then we must rely on
God that's the situation we are in now
this is some see a dot a 23
8:11 BC so here you have one of these
great Syrian rulers and notice what he
has around his neck and he is one of
those powerful rulers and there is the
symbol of a new also the star of Ishtar
so there's a male deity and there's a
female deity and he has authority who's
Authority does he have and under whose
Mach does he rule under the Mark of Cain
now we studied the these are Taric
writings and we saw with that led to so
let's go back to them this is again
morals and dogma the degree rose and
then he uses the symbol is that the same
symbol that you saw on the Assyrian King
yes teaches three things the unity
immutability and goodness of God so
there's an element of religion here the
immortality of the soul is that the true
God or false God it's a false God and
the ultimate defeat an extinction of
evil and wrong and sorrow by a Redeemer
or Messiah yet to come
if he has not already appeared excuse me
is this the same Messiah we're waiting
for no so here is a religion but it's
not the religion of God it's another
religion and it's a false religion but
this degree the rose uses this as its
sign and here are the symbols of the
Rosicrucians they use the phoenix rising
out of the ashes and they use the symbol
of the pelican feeding its young now
without the shedding of blood there is
no redemption and the lamb had to die in
order to symbolize the death and the
resurrection of Jesus here is a
sacrifice which is made to feed the
children but the creature does not die
so it's a false religion it's a false
religion and this was the symbol that
was used that the last Olympics in
London where the furnace arises out of
the ashes so the rulers
the world used the symbol that is used
in the Rosicrucian symbolism so the
current rulers of the world haven't
suddenly changed
they haven't suddenly become God's
people if you go to Roman Catholicism
you'll find both of these emblems in the
Roman Catholic Church and the Beast
which I saw was like unto a leopard and
his feet were as the feet of a bear and
his mouth as the mouth of a lion and the
dragon gave him his power and his seat
and what great Authority who according
to the scripture wields the authority
today the beasts the beasts now every
reformer said that this was Roman
Catholicism there's no doubt about it
that this was Roman Catholicism Thomas
Woodrow Wilson since I entered politics
I have chiefly had men's views confided
to me privately some of the biggest men
in the United States in the field of
Commerce and manufacture are afraid of
somebody are afraid of something they
know that there is a power somewhere so
organized so subtle so watchful so
interlocked so complete so pervasive
that they had better not speak above
their breath when they speak in
condemnation of it there was the
President of the United States who
handed over the financial power of the
United States to the Federal Reserve
fascinating Liberty has never come from
the government this is the president of
the United States speaking Liberty has
always come from the subjects of the
government the history of Liberty is a
history of resistance the history of
Liberty is a history of the limitation
of governmental power not the increase
of it so when governmental power
increases they are exercising an
authority and it's an authority that
comes all the way down from the line of
Enoch
the Rosicrucians who use the very symbol
there it is that we found on their
Syrian kings and they are subject to the
Roman sea and today we have two popes
ruling although one sits on the throne
and both of them have these powers under
their control and here is the current
general of the Jesuits Adolfo nicolás
and he rules over forces that we will
see are all encompassing now let's go to
the great controversy I specifically
chose the great controversy because
isn't this a project of this church
just checking throughout Christendom
Protestantism was menaced by formidable
foes Protestantism was menaced the first
triumphs of the Reformation past Rome
summoned new forces hoping to accomplish
its destruction at this time the order
of the Jesuits was created now please
note I'm not saying this the most cruel
unscrupulous and powerful of all the
champions of popery
the most cruel cut off from every
earthly tie and human interest dead to
the claims of natural affection reason
and conscience only silence then you no
rule no tie but that of their order and
no duty was to extend its power the
gospel of Christ had enabled its
adherents to meet a danger and during
suffering undismayed by cold hunger and
toil poverty to uphold the banner of
truth in the face of the wreck the
dungeon and the stake to combat these
forces Jesuit ISM inspired its followers
with a fanaticism that enabled them to
endure lack dangers and to oppose to the
power of truth all the weapons of
deception there was no crime too great
for them to commit no deception to base
for them to practice no disguise too
difficult for them to assume vowed to
perpetual poverty and humility
it was the studied aim to
secur wealth and power to be devoted to
the overthrow of Protestantism and the
reestablishment of the papal supremacy
that's from the pen of inspiration the
Inquisition was unscrupulous it was
cruel now the Jesuits were given the
Inquisition in Rome not to be confused
with the Spanish Inquisition which was
run by the Dominicans but in Rome the
Jesuits
at the heart of power they were the
inquisitors the tools they used for
torture were renders this thing was put
around your neck and that screw
tightened until your larynx gave way and
you died and it was used as recently as
in the Franco wars in Spain they used
the thumbscrews they tied people to a
host and tied a heavy ball and then
dropped it down so that their limbs
would be ripped from their bodies they
burned people at the stake the most
incredible tortures these are drawings
and pictures of actual events that took
place this is how they tied them up and
then they dropped that ball they were so
cruel it is unbelievable
and the spirit of prophecy says these
were the champions and here you have the
present black Pope and the present white
Pope and today we have some
unprecedented history we have two
current popes and we have for the first
time in history two black popes because
not only Ratzinger retired but Peter
Hans Calvin Bach also retired for the
first time in history is the work so
great that they have to divide the world
into two parts and they are at the
disposal of this mighty machine here is
the present Pope in the company of the
Jesuits because the first thing when a
pope is elected is he meets with the
jesuit
and his highest authorities Adolfo
nicolás the black Pope and bergoglio the
white Pope they seem very happy about
something very happy both of the magis
Christian example of Pope Francis
provides a contrast with the graceless
but who would ever have believed his
successor could be a Francis from the
ends of the earth a Jesuit nor so ran in
the 2005 Conclave the poorest of the
poor know the great surprise about
Francis isn't that he's so Christian he
walks the walk so many prelates he
content to just talk the talk he showed
the trappings of his office to live
frugally in Borna Cyrus he took the bus
but to go and visit the Pope just next
door talk the helicopter and he was
elected on the 13th of the 3rd 2013 at
the numbers it comes to 13 and the smoke
appeared at five past 8:00 at the
numbers it comes to 13 and yesterday he
went to Assisi and his departure time is
exact and his return time is exact
you'll spend exactly 13 hours in Assisi
and his name is Francis is it Francis of
Assisi oh is it Francis Xavier the
co-founder of the Jesuit Order who
ordered the Inquisition in Goa and
proclaimed that all Sabbath keepers
there should be destroyed I am
fascinated with this man here he is seen
kissing the feet of prisoners if you
look carefully still wears his black
robes under his white robe as you can
see over there there is his symbol in
the bus that I want to discuss that
picture further and let's read the great
controversy when a
peirong as members of the order they
were ago wore a garb of sanctity
visiting prisons and hospitals
ministering to the sick and to the poor
I'm reading from the great controversy
professing to ever announce the world
and bearing the sacred name of Jesus who
went about doing good but under this
blameless exterior the most criminal and
deadly purposes were concealed it was a
fundamental principle of the order that
the end justifies the means by this code
lying theft perjury assassination were
not only pardonable but commendable when
they served the interests of the church
and a various disguises the Jesuits
worked their way into offices of state
climbing up to be the councilors of
Kings shaping the policy of Nations
they became servants to act the spies
upon their masters they established
colleges for the sons of princes and
Nobles and schools for the common people
and the children of Protestant parents
were drawn into observance of purpose
rites that's what the pain of
inspiration tells us two swords a
medieval doctrine on the relation of
church and state as explained by Pope
Boniface the eighth we are taught by the
word of the gospel that in this church
and under her control there are two
swords the spiritual and the temporal
this is the Pope speaking both of these
the spiritual and the temporal swords
are under the control of the church who
has the mark of authority according to
this the church which Church wrong the
first is wielded by the church the
second is wielded on behalf of the
church the first is wielded by the hands
of the priests the second by the hands
of kings and soldiers but at the wish
and by the permission of the priests
sword must be subordinate to sword and
his only fitting that temporal Authority
should be subject to the spiritual this
doctrine was not defined by the Pope but
reflected the mentality of the age when
both priests and Kings were members of
the same Catholic Church in whose name
post Boniface was speaking for the John
Henson modern Catholic dictionary this
is their writings they control the sword
they wield the sword of authority they
have the mark of power this is the
Pope's bull unum sanctum we are informed
by the text of the gospel that in this
church and in its power are two swords
the spiritual and the temporary for when
the Apostle says behold there are two
swords that is to say in the church
since the apostles were speaking the
Lord did not reply that there were too
many but sufficient we'll talk about
that text in a moment certainly the one
who denies that the temporal sword is in
the power of Peter has not listened well
to the word of the Lord commanding put
up thy sword unto thy scabbard both
therefore in the power of the church
that is to say the spiritual and the
material sword but the four mains to be
administered for the church but the
letter by the church the former in the
hand of the priest the latter in the
hands of kings and soldiers but at the
will and sufferance of the priest who
controls the church however one sort or
two be subordinate to the other and
temporal Authority subjected to
spiritual power for since the Apostle
said there is no power except from God
and the things that are ordained of God
Romans 13:1 and two but they would not
be ordained if one-third what no sword
were not subordinate to the other and if
the inferior were FIRREA one as it were
were not laid upwards by the other
furthermore we declare we proclaim we
define that it is absolutely necessary
for salvation that every human creature
be subject to the Roman pontiff now I
didn't take this from some obscure
source I made sure I took it directly
from the Vatican webpage so check it out
there for yourselves now let's look at
this text Luke 22 35 and he this is
Jesus speaking how this text has been
distorted is amazing and he said to them
when said I sent you without person
scrip and shoes Lackey anything and they
said nothing okay let's just get one
thing clear God's people how did he sent
them out without script without purse
right now I say then said he unto them
but now he that has a purse how would
they sent out help me without purse so
now I was referring to another Clause
those that had the purse those that have
the power over the economy those that
have the power over the sword but now he
that has a purse let him take it and
likewise his script that's his knapsack
and he that has no sword let him sell
His garment and buy one this is war
this is wrong for I say unto you that
this that is written must yet be
accomplished in me and he was reckoned
amongst the transgressors for the things
concerning me have an end and they said
Lord behold there are two sorts and he
said unto them it is enough what did
Jesus say to them Jesus said to my dear
disciple
I don't think you understood what I just
said I said to you I sent you out
without purse but there's another class
that has the purse and that has the
sword and I the son of man will now be
handed over to them and they will use
that authority and they will crucify me
but they didn't understand so they said
the Lord look we've got two swords and
Jesus says no please I'm not talking
about your stupid little sword it's
enough he's talking about those who
wield the authority those who have the
Mark of Cain who are going to kill him
it's not the church that must wield the
sword it is those who rule over the
children of evil Thomas Aquinas said the
Pope by divine right has spiritual and
temporal power as supreme king of the
world
he is the king the Pope of Rome is the
head of the papal government claims
absolute sovereignty and supremacy over
all the governments of the earth that is
they're saying the right of deposing
Kings is inherent in the supreme
sovereignty of the Pope's as vice regent
of Christ exercises over all Christian
nations this is what they claim and
whose sign do we see there we see the
sign of Honor the very one that mad
Dooku or the one that emphasizes the
power now we'll follow it a little bit
but we will do that in the next episode
I'm sure we all need a sword break so
let's take a short break and come back
for the second off
[Applause]
[Music]
as we saw in the first half the rulers
who have received power to rule over the
children of disobedience have a certain
mindset which may be suppressed for long
periods of time but when it manifests
itself it is the same mindset that was
manifested by Herod so the huronian mind
is one that is in enmity with God even
though it has power over God's people
the Rodian mindset will also try to make
the worship of God subject to his own
ideology because Herod put the Eagle of
Rome on the temple of Yahweh that he
restored so this mindset can be followed
all the way through history and when it
culminates in oppressive regulations and
rules which contradict God's law then
God says probation is over that in brief
summary of what we've said so far we saw
that the mark of Honor is central to the
Roman power now let's have a look at
another piece revelation 13:11 and I
held another beast coming up out of the
earth and he had two horns like a lamb
and he spoke as a dragon and he
exercises all the power of the first
beast before him what kind of power does
the first beast claim to have it says it
has two swords the one is the spiritual
power and the other one is the temporal
power and that the spiritual power is
over the temporal power we saw those
papal encyclicals who wields the second
sword on his behalf in the world we are
living in today well the Bible tells us
I beheld another beast coming up out of
the earth and he had two horns like a
lamb and he spoke like a dragon and he
exercises all the power of the first
beast before him on his behalf and
causes the earth and then the dwelling
to worship the first beast whose deadly
wound was healed so the power the
secular arm of power that he wields and
uses is particularly manifested in the
second beast which is the United States
of America and here is the Capitol and
on top of the Capitol you have a female
deity Paris the fullness Venus if you
like she is the same as the Easter the
ruler of the night the consort of Marduk
who was given authority to rule over the
children of evil now a copy tall can
only be subject to the god Jupiter
because he was the Capitol and that is
the god of road and so we have the
similarities in architecture and the one
is subject to the other but the female
deity the deity of the rulership of the
children of Darkness in an occult
fashion contrary to the worship of God
but supposedly subject to him and if you
come to pass says 1 Kings 1917 that him
that Escapist the sword of Hazael shall
ye who slay and him that escaped Earth
from the sword of year who shall Elisha
slay
yet I have left me seven thousand in
Israel all the knees
have not bowed unto bail and every mouth
which has not kissed him so God uses the
temporal power to punish even God's
people when they are apostate and he has
done this many times over
has he not used those who claim
rulership of the children of
disobedience
to punish God's people in the past yes
or no he certainly has and history
becomes just so much clearer if we
understand these things because people
are confused how can God do this how can
this happen we are living on a planet of
disobedience and God by permitting this
is extending the hour of grace and
giving an opportunity now the sword that
comes out of the mouth of Elijah is that
an earthly sword oh is that a spiritual
sword it simply means that those who
don't accept the message that comes out
of the mouth of Elijah who wears the
cloak of Elijah in other words the
Elijah message they will die they will
die and there was fall subject to the
other sword which is in the hands of
jail and he also served the Lord in
sorts but the Bible says his heart was
not right and he served other gods and
he followed the ways of Jeroboam but he
was still used as a sword but he saves
the poor from the sword from their mouth
from their mouth and from the hand of
the mighty now the poor here of course
are those who are destroyed in spirit
those who seek something better who seek
the Lord this is not talking about
literal poverty and Jared Joab said make
ready and his chariot was made ready and
joram king of Israel and as i acting of
judah went out each in his chariot and
they went out against Jo and
the portion of neighbor the jezreelite
it is a very fascinating story we'll do
a little bit more about this in the
second half now we know that I have
coveted neighbor's vineyard and
eventually Jezebel who serves as a type
of the church and gave it to him by her
authority but this is where he meets him
and it came to pass when char
Joanne saw Jehu that he said is a piece
child and he answered what piece so long
as the whoredoms of thy mother Jezebel
and now which crafts are so many that
counts for today - there can be no peace
as long as the whoredoms of Jezebel are
so many there can be no peace it is war
from the beginning and I will put enmity
this war hasn't stopped but I've got
good news for you it's coming to a head
this is the black obelisk of shamaness
at the third showing Jehu paying tribute
so here is his obelisk and there is Jehu
and he is paying tribute this was a
prince of Israel this is the sword was
given to him to correct the faults in
Israel he slew all the descendants of
Ahab and eventually he also slew Jezebel
typologically this is a fascinating
story but there's something else that's
very interesting about this here is
shamaness of the third and here is his
symbol of authority can you see that so
this man Jehu who was ruling and was
king in israel was only ruling as king
subject to whom subject to Salman Issa
now if you take some Aneesa down the
line of history you go through the
babylonian kings the same authority
stayed with them then the medo-persians
then the Greeks then the Romans and then
papal Rome they all followed the same
line and anybody who rules and wields
the sword must be subject to the king of
Babylon now there's something else
that's fascinating about this you can't
see the whole of it here but this a
little bit more in this reconstruction
they all wearing cute little hats Jay
who is wearing one there it is and those
carrying the tribute are also wearing
some can you see that what is also
interesting is that these people have
beards Jo has appeared and these have
beards but these two servants of Psalm
Aneesa and that one don't have beards
what does that tell you they were
eunuchs in the court of the King and
because they have this little funny
little hat if you take this hat through
all the way through history it has a
connotation with the god mitra ism mitra
but mid-rise just a further continuance
of the sun god and in a sense later it
became the Phrygian cap and it became
the cap of the revolution in France
where freedom was given to the citizens
so the Hat the Phrygian hat is a symbol
of subservience to the sun-god but it is
also a symbol of being a free man
and as a free man you could procreate
you won't castrate you could procreate
and you could rule and you could be free
on one condition
and that was you can only
free and a free man if you are subject
to the ruler who has the sign and the
mark of our nose then you could be free
then you could be free now before you go
too far
in our previous sermon we said you can
either be slaves to righteousness or
slaves to unrighteousness God's people
will also bow down to a ruler because
the Bible says every knee will bow that
includes God's people right but the
difference is this this one is by
compulsion and fear the other one will
be out of free choice so who is really
free only those who serve Jesus Christ
so there's little hat this Phrygian hat
over here means I am free man I'm a free
man but I am subservient now if you were
a part of the occult line then these
symbols were all used now in Freemasonry
they trace their origin of their rituals
that they have today to the Knights
Templars and they were great builders of
castles and banks and builders builders
builders they don't remind us of
something coming down that line and they
were called for Mr song which means
brother Masons but if you transliterated
directly into English eventually it
becomes free mason and the word free
gets another connotation other than a
brotherly guilt it's also I am free I
can be what I want to be provided I bow
I bow so the god mitra wore this little
hat as was worn by jay who
so I don't want the little hat you can
keep it but the United States Senate has
what they're in its emblem the little
hat and the United States military has
what they're in its symbol so is it the
symbol of subservience to the king of
babylon yes or no yes and are they free
yes they are free masong they are free
true they are free to exercise the power
on behalf of the other one but they
really they are in bondage to a system
if you want to read an interesting book
then get rulers of evil and it comes out
in two covers one has the God as it is
in on the Great Dome of the Capitol
building where there is marvelous
symbolism and here you have this female
deity wielding the sword over the
children of disobedience and it also has
the god mercury on the dome the
mercurial God the Pied Piper who leads
by deceit people into hard days and who
is the god of commerce and finances the
revolution of the colonies against
Britain all the symbolism is in there
the same as you will find the symbolism
in Rome but this cover is rather
revealing because the symbol of Honor is
placed on the chest of whom there which
priest what kind of priest Jesuit priest
and I found this fascinating that a man
who doesn't have the prophecies that we
have and there's great privilege that we
have can come to such conclusions was
mind-boggling the preface of the book
was written by
journalist Pat Shannon and he writes a
very fascinating preface he says the
only people in the world it seems who
believe in conspiracy theory of history
are those of us who have studied it he
makes another statement later on he says
you will read this book from cover to
cover and you will highlight it over and
over and over again he said make sure
that you put it on the bottom of your
shelf that all your children will
someday get hold of it and then he
continues and says while Franklin D
Roosevelt might have exaggerated when he
said nothing happens in politics by
accident
if it happens it was planned that way
carroll quigley now let me tell you
carroll quigley was he was the Jesuit of
Georgetown University who was the
lecturer of the presidents that studied
there and of all the great people that
rule in America amongst others both
clinton carroll quigley writes bill
clinton's favorite professor at
georgetown university boldly admitted in
his tragedy and hope written in 1966
that a the multitudes were already under
the control of a small but powerful
group bent on world domination and be
that Quigley was a Jesuit himself was
part of that group so out of the mouth
of the professor of Georgetown
University the Jesuit University he says
there's a group of powerful elite that
rules the world in his part of it
interesting interesting well I wonder
what this man learnt there let's see
what he learned and a special thanks to
the members of the Roosevelt family who
were here and the one who is not Eleanor
who made sure that the Four Freedoms
were included
the preamble to the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights in 1948 I
know that because as all of you famously
learned when I served as president my
wife now the Secretary of State was
known to commune with eleanor on a
regular basis and so she called me last
night on her way home from Peru to
remind me to say that Eleanor had talked
to her and reminded her that I should
say that now my question is this this is
a ruler his ear was he ruling according
to the dictates of God yes or no judging
by what you just heard no so he's a
ruler over the children who would
worship God according to their own
methodologies that correct please don't
misunderstand me God loves them God
reaches out to them God wants them all
to be saved if he went to the trouble
that he went to for Nebuchadnezzar and
he went to the same trouble even more so
in the case of Herod then I am convinced
that he will do the same for these
presidents don't misunderstand me I'm
just discussing a historic scenario so
spiritism forms part and parcel of the
way in which government is enacted
because under the Reagan administration
they used astrology and divination to
determine how they were going to run
things when they were going to meet what
days that were going to do what
everything ran according to a knockout
calendar that's common history everybody
knows it and how we have out of the
horse's mouth that the Secretary of
State receives instruction from a
deceased individual probably also as to
how to run affairs of state now Lauren's
our Rick
the 18th Superior General of the Society
of Jesus is a fascinating man because he
ruled from 1773 to 1814 which means that
he also ruled in the time period when
the first beast received a mortal wound
and it is fascinating that the black
papacy also received a mortal wound
because it was apparently fanned and
disbanded but then had a resurrection
just like the white papacy now during
the order suppression from 1773 to 1814
by Pope Clement general Ricci created
the Illuminati with his soldiers he
didn't go underground because he was to
be destroyed he went underground because
it was convenient remember that the
first peace seemed to have a mortal
wound it doesn't say it had a mortal
wound it seemed to have a mortal wound
I don't I saw the father of modern
communism who was with the jacobeans who
wear the little hat who may rules
subservient to the system conducted the
French Revolution years later Jesuit
general leader Chavez gave this one with
his Bolsheviks conducted the Russian
Revolution 1917 it being identical to
the upheaval of 1789 history of the
Jesuits
so who fermented this tremendous
political upheaval the Jesuits behind
the scenes they are the secret rulers of
evil ex quarter mala Bishop and this man
actually is a Canadian today he lives in
Canada East claims Jesuits are the
spiritual controllers of the New World
Order and this is what he has to say I'm
quoting now some
sources view I quoted rulers of evil now
I'm quoting a Catholic bishop former
bishop Gareth Beaufort of Guatemala said
the Vatican is the real spiritual
controller of the Illuminati and the new
world order
while the Jesuits threw the black Pope
Jesuit general friar Peter hunts Calvin
ba who is now no longer the general so
he wrote this a little while ago the
president was Adolfo nicolás but they're
both still alive actually control the
Vatican hierarchy and the Roman Catholic
Church
Bishop fr who left the church and is now
born-again Christian living in Canada
based his conclusion of the working six
years as Vatican priests assigned the
task of passing daily sensitive
correspondence between the Pope and the
leaders of the Jesuit Order residing at
Bordeaux Santo Spirito five near st.
Peter's Square yes the man known as the
black Pope controls all major decisions
made by the Pope and he in turn controls
the Illuminati said bishop of fog last
week on greg Szymanski's radio show the
investigative journalist and soul where
archives of the startling statements can
be heard in the entirely I know this to
be true since I worked four years in the
Vatican and traveled with Pope John Paul
the second the Pope takes his marching
orders from the black Pope as the
Jesuits also are the leaders of the New
World Order with the task of
infiltrating other religions and
governments of the world in order to
bring about a one-world fascist
government and a one world religion
based on Satanism and Lucifer now in
case someone says I'm a conspiracies
I didn't say it he said people can't
imagine how evil and how much
destruction they have caused and will
cause while at the same time using the
perfect cover of hiding behind black
robes and professing to be men of God
and just want to ask a question is what
we read here in harmony with what we
read out of the great controversy yes
not and that is the final question if we
can say that that book must go to the
world then why is it that we war against
what that book has to say this is the
Church of the Gesu Italian kids or del
gesù and notice that it is a G and in
Freemasonry the letter inside is a G
which has many meanings
the naive will say it means God no it
will tell you who the real man is behind
the power and in that chapel you have
the famous statue of the church with a
what is that in the hand over here
a lightning bolts who carried the
lightning bolt in our first little
picture
it was Marduk who carried it and with
his lightning bolt through that power of
that divinity which is a transcript of
Kane who received the power from Anu
with that power she will destroy
Protestantism this is Lutheran Calvo and
that is a mission if that were not her
mission today why doesn't she cover up
this little statue
why does she leave it there see my lord
from this room from this room I governed
not only Paris but China not only China
but the whole world without anyone
knowing how that's managed Michelangelo
tamburini the 1728 general of the
Jesuits speaking to the Duke of Bronchos
revelation 17 verse 15 says and he says
unto the me the waters which thou sawest
where the sitteth are people's and
multitudes and nations and tongues how
much does she control everything so what
happens in China what happens in Japan
what happens in Korea is what's supposed
to happen to channel people into a
mindset one mindset which will finally
come into direct conflict
with another mindset because this is the
battle for the mind does she control the
secret police of the world the answer is
yes the CIA was formed by Catholic
knight of Malta William Wild Bill
Donovan he's considered the father of
the CIA the FBI was also formed by a
knight of Malta trustee of the Catholic
University of America when Loyola was
traveling with the permission of the
Pope to Jerusalem a knight of Malta a
high General of the Knights of Malta was
with him on the ship and Loyola received
the secrets of the power structure
directly from the Knights of Malta so
the two are really one today that's
history you can check it out
the grand design exposed the truth is
the Jesuits of Rome have perfected
Freemasonry to be their most magnificent
and effective tool accomplishing their
purpose among Protestants so in
Protestant nations the Freemason
organizations all feel very comfortable
but the stop structure is subject to
someone they don't even know who it is
and that someone is the black Pope in
Rome Malachi Martin who was strangely
removed from this planet said it is a
strange phenomenon in history of the
Roman Church that every time there is a
crisis of extraordinary value new
Masonic orders are called forth and that
is how the Jesuit came into being it
took over the top structure it received
it as a gift it was the new ruler on
this planet so if you go to the Capitol
it is a temple of Jupiter and on top of
it says the goddess and it's interesting
that the Capitol on Venus this great
statue in Rome that was removed only
once during the French Revolution from
Rome
when the papacy received a mortal wound
was recently sent to Washington as a
symbol of their unity and Washington of
course laid the cornerstone Masonic Lee
now this is the great Scottish Rite of
Freemasonry Supreme Council 33 degrees
now it is a museum but parts of it are
open to the public but as you all know
we are a little bit naughty my friend in
the back there and I and so while they
were showing us around we managed to
sneak off into other places but this is
where the great leaders actually meet
after their decisions are made in the
Senate's and other places and the real
power is determined over here so we took
some pictures that were not part of the
tour and what do you see as you come in
there you see the sign of a new as worn
by some ash and mud Duke this is in this
Lodge where the leadership of the United
States meets now we're just going to go
through and you see its symbol over
there which is the symbol of power
here's the Supreme Court of the United
States what is the symbol that you see
on the wall over there it's the exact
same symbol we our rulers over the
powers of evil and we will keep them in
check we will make laws and we will make
everybody subject to our laws but the
supreme leaders also have another
criterion they are in conflict with God
and were the followers of God and their
intent eventually is always to get rid
of Abel or to get rid of the children of
Israel
or to get rid of the Prince of Peace or
to get rid of those who followed the
Prince of Peace or to get rid of the
remnant of the remnant do you see the
picture throughout history is there any
reason why it shouldn't repeat itself so
the sign of an O is on the Supreme Court
of the United States of America now I'll
take you down into the places where they
didn't take us
welcome to the J Edgar Hoover room
dedicated to your law enforcement
community and then there's something
written here which is hard to read
unless you carefully look at it so I
wrote it out for you the most effective
weapon against crime is cooperation the
effort of all law enforcement agency
with the support and understanding of
the American people who wields the sword
the United States of America on behalf
of whom on behalf of the first peace the
secular power is subject to the
spiritual power
FBI activities began under mr. Hoover's
era and there are some of the examples
and just to make sure you know what went
on with him he must have been at least
the 32 degree Freemason because he's a
shrine and you have to be a 32 degree
freemason to be that but he was probably
33 so there is it's interesting that he
has the symbol of the the moon and the
star we think it is Islam it has nothing
to do with it this is the symbol of Isis
and Horus it is that symbol of power
given by that first parent given by Cain
and his wife to their son you know and
down through the line through masonry
according to pike who traces their
history back to the power of enough to
rule here is shaking hands with the
President of the United States
eisenhower our new cities are they
builders of cities yes
very much so who's this gentleman this
is taken in that Lodge by the way in
that room in that room in that Lodge
that's Billy Graham shaking hands with
Hoover there is with the Pope and he
declared the Pope to be the moral leader
of the world is that Jehu bowing down
yes or no and here you have norman
vincent peale
33 degree freemason took this picture
myself down there in the 33 degree
Washington Lodge this is the father of
the modern mega church this is the
father of the modern methodology used in
the church who's he subject to Rome says
that the temporal power is subject to
the spiritual power and that spiritual
power resides in Rome he's the father of
the megachurch movement he was the
mentor of Robert Schuller who became the
mentor of Hybels and of Rick Warren and
the whole plethora of modern theology
comes out of this temple Lodge here is
Harry Truman 33 degree Freemason and
there is the altar inside that shrine
now if you look at that altar it's a
replica of what it's a replica of the
altar of offering that was used by the
Hebrews but on top of it is not only the
Bible but the bhagavad-gita the Tanakh
the Quran and the Bible what does that
symbolize that all religions will be
fused into one
so is this children of obedience or
children of disobedience is this a way
to God of your own devising or
the way the truth and the life nobody
comes to the Father except by me well we
can see that quite clearly Alice a
Bailey founders of Lucifer Trust said
there will be no dissociation between
the universal Church the sacred lodge of
all true Masons and the inner circle of
the esoteric societies in this way the
goals and the work of the United Nations
will be solidified and a new church of
God led by all the religions and by all
the spiritual groups shall put to an end
the great heresy of separateness so if
the Bible says come up and be separate
and have nothing to do with this kind of
worship they say the opposite so these
are rulers of evil another 33 degree
Freemason we senator Doe and here you
have Burke showing that the military
power is also under their control this
is all taken directly from the pictures
hanging down there and we also happen to
step on the holy ground of Albert Pike's
grave and they were horrified
oh you're standing on holy ground what's
the holy about that Pike is here
[Music]
unbelievable then Stein noted that the
leading American players behind Reagan
Vatican conspiracy to a man were devout
Roman Catholics namely William Casey now
this book was written in 1971 those
rulers of evil I just want you to note
the names and see where these people or
some of them are today William Casey was
then that time director of the CIA
Richard Allen national security adviser
national security adviser and hi
Secretary of State ambassador at large
when Walters ambassador to the Vatican
Wilson but the reporter neglected to
mention that the entire Senate Foreign
Relations Committee was governed by
Roman Catholics as well especially Joe
Biden wizzy today
Subcommittee on European fairs Paul
sabonis international economic policy in
oceans and environment when John Kerry
where is he today terrorism narcotics
and international communications was his
portfolio then so do they control very
interesting aspects fascinating and of
course they were bones men as we know
now people will start shouting
conspiracy there's no conspiracy there's
a fact this is not conspiracy now let's
have a look at some modern people Leon
Panetta he was the former director of
the Central Intelligence Agency Leon
Edward Panetta is an American politician
lawyer and professor
he served in a Barack Obama's
administration as director of the
Central Intelligence Agency from 2009 to
11 and a secretary of defense from 2011
to 2013 in 1956 he entered Santa Clara
University and in 1960 he graduated
magna laude with a Bachelor arts and
political side he also received the
Juris Doctor from Santa Clara University
he joined the United States Army
etcetera etc etc he receives the army
commendation medal and was discharged in
1966 as first lieutenant so running
these mighty organizations we have Roman
Catholic agents al Jazeera says the
dangerous rebranding of John Brennan
he's the current director of the CIA now
where is he get his training how does
this happen how can a constitutional law
professor and community activist and a
Jesuit trained intelligent analyst with
an interest in Just War Theory so easily
distort language etc etc are really
interested in the details who controls
him his Jesuit trained well Clinton was
Jesuit trained the CIA the FBI to this
day they were founded by agents of Rome
and today agents of Rome are controlling
them today
nothing has changed the Tower of Babel
and here
you have the Queen of Heaven and her
little child Horace on the Tower of
Babel Rome makes note that makes no
secret of its affiliations he
dissociates itself with the Tower of
Babel
she's the quaint queen of Babel God
divided the nation's and it's been
satan's aim to reunite them in apostasy
against God and we are heading for that
final apostasy the European Parliament
building is nothing other than a
reconstruction of the Tower of Babel
this was at the London Olympics there
you had the five rings of the Olympics
which symbolise the union of the five
continents a one-world government but
it's not complete until the capstone
comes down on it and who's the goddess
of the night
Isis and so they planned it precisely
according to the astrological and
astronomical column calendar so that the
full moon would rise and join the rings
to complete the pyramids and whether
it's inverted or whether it's upright
makes no difference the one is the
malefactor the other one is the female
factor the world is coming to the point
who win this one world unity which will
be in opposition to God is coming into
effect this is the journal America the
National Catholic Review it is a Jesuit
journal so let's ask the Jesuits to
explain who the president of the
European Council today is he was
educated at the Catholic University of
Leuven which is dedicated to Mary the
mother of Jesus under a traditional
attribute the seat of wisdom we'll have
to talk about that now let's see what
the Jesuit journal has to say one
interesting thing about mr. Romm Phan
rompe is his Catholicism about which he
makes no
Bonz he was educated the rum roll civil
play by Jesuits in Brussels the top
leaders in the world are Jesuits or
Jesuit trained they wield the power this
is the emblem of Georgetown University
was taken directly from their web page
the scene of Georgetown University it
bears the founding date 1789 the
University our motto throught unum both
into one and Latin inscription Collegium
giorgio platinum at the repast whatever
which means Georgetown College on the
banks of the Potomac in Maryland this is
where the presidents get educated this
is where the legislators get educated
they have the Roman Eagle and it says
both into one if you check a little bit
further on their web page they will lie
to you or on other web pages about this
and they will say to you oh this is the
dividing line between the Jew and the
Gentile that has been taken away and
they have been united nonsense this is
the union of church and state the union
of church and state this is what will be
achieved whether we like it or not and
it will be under the auspices of the
Roman Eagle and that is why there's a
holy Alliance which was formed between
the two and the ego forms part of the
Pontifex Maximus assemble on the very
seat of his power I took that picture in
the Vatican on the floor as you enter
some Peters and there is the emblem and
this is the symbol of the United States
of America and it has exactly the same
thing here it says in Latin he God
favored our undertaking and a new order
of the ages you know these things here
is
the symbol of the eagle in Rome under
the papal keys on the coin of the
Vatican and here is the famous eagle as
it is in the garden of the Vatican
sculpted by paul v now this is a
statement that some say he never made
but many claim that he did make it and
even if he didn't make it exactly like
that this is found in others of his
writings almost like this so we can say
it's quite Authority Woodrow Wilson
wrote I'm the most unhappy man I have
unwittingly ruined my country a great
industrial nation is controlled by its
system of credit our system of credit is
concentrated the growth of the nation
therefore in all our activities on the
hands of a few men we have come to be
one of the worst ruled one of the most
completely controlled and dominated
governments in the civilized world no
longer a government by free opinion no
longer a government by conviction and
the vote of the majority but a
government by the opinion and Duras of a
small group of dominant men and he said
that after he signed into law the
federal reserve now this is the Globe
and Mail Business Report 10 September
2013 the CEOs of some of the world's top
mining companies did not come to the
Vatican to pray see Pope Francis or
traipse through the sweltering halls of
the Vatican Museum they came to discuss
ways to make their industry a little bit
less devilish and you have to give the
Vatican credit for all-star drawing
power any mining conference would have
been envious of the guestlist Saturday
is day of reflection with the mining
industry which was organized by the
Pontifical Council for justice and peace
the Vatican department that deals with
earthly matters such as promoting human
rights included the C and O's CEOs of
Anglo American PLC area tented in
newmont mining these three men alone
represented companies with well more
than 100
billion US dollars in market value
discussions taking place at the Vatican
Bilderberg 2000 and work in 13 welcome
to 1984 of the 59 years of Bilderberg
guests scuttling through the shadows
ducking lenses etc etc here they come
and there is this lady Acharya who is
the IMF boss today she's above the burka
in my previous lecture I showed that the
bulgar burgers were formed and started
by the Jesuits now here's an interview
which is rather fascinating and this
interview if we can have the sound up in
a moment this interview is with a
whistleblower
now what's the blower's are causing
quite a bit of trouble for the current
regimes and this is no ordinary
whistleblower this was one of the
advisory lawyers in the international
monetary form this is one of the
whistleblowers who blew the whistle on
multi billion frauds and eventually for
whistleblowing she got a pink slip then
let's listen to what this person were
there in fact within the financial
systems of the world has come up with in
her thinking hello I'm Greg hunter
welcome to us a watchdog calm with us
today a brand new guest her name is
karen buddhist she is an attorney she is
a baker and she is a whistle blower
karen buddhist thank you so much for
joining us today from maryland thank you
so much well you work for the world bank
for a better part of twenty years you
are a Ivy League trained attorney you
are with the Ivy League school are you
with the Yale you you work for the World
Bank as a lawyer you're a banker and you
were a whistleblower inside the World
Bank not just one time but several times
a crescendo do with a big almost a
billion dollar you know whistleblowing
fraud malfeasance in the World Bank in
Indonesia and for that you got a pink
slip in 2009 getting back to the Federal
Reserve and the Bank for International
Settlements
these groups are in cahoots with the
biggest crooks of all the Jesuits that
bought a Bank of America and they have
little secret deals to try to apportion
the riches of the world and in the
meantime all of the countries of the
world know that this thievery is going
on we are talking about the biggest
thuggery of all and that is the Jesuits
in the Vatican and let me tell you what
I just found out I always thought that
the CIA was the problem and the you know
the other intelligence agencies guess
what there's a grand intelligence agency
that the Vatican puts out and all of
those other crooks are operating under
the Vatican intelligence agency the
money is though not the money is about
the control and the the Vatican
intelligence agency the world
intelligence agent about we're fighting
over money over what money we're gonna
use that controls the money I'm saying
Greg they're not fighting they've all
agreed the fighting is what we're led to
believe they're all in cahoots just like
all the banks are in boots
all of these intelligence agencies are
in cahoots to for example people don't
know that they're IRS revenue is going
to the Vatican now there's a
whistleblower and I don't think she's a
fool I think she saw through it Pope
John the 23rd made the following
statement the Mark of Cain is stamped
upon our foreheads across the country is
our brother Abel was slain in the blood
which we drew and shed tears we caused
by forgetting thy love forgive us Lord
for the curse we falsely attributed to
their name as Jews forgive us for
crucifying the second time in their
flesh for we knew not what we did now
lest I be accused of being an
anti-semite I am not lest I be accused
of being an anti-catholic I am NOT I'm
anteye anyone I'm just Pro Jesus Christ
but he claims the Mark of Cain is
stamped upon their foreheads
he's a stating effect he knows it they
have the Mark of Cain they have the
authority to rule and they are
exercising the authority and what he
says is that they slew Abel all over
again in the form of the Jews but they
want to be forgiven for that does he ask
forgiveness for the inquisition and the
slaughter of millions of Christians no
because those who reject Christ
a part of his mindset so all that he has
done in the statement has said the Mark
of Cain is on upon our phorid and we
welcome into our midst
anyone who has the same enmity against
Jesus Christ that's what he's saying but
they're clever they hide it under this
language so that you will not see it
Netanyahu thanks the Pope for Jewish
exoneration soper Benedict went a step
further and exonerated them from the
guilt of the crucifixion he's very kind
he wields the power he has the mark of
Adam he can do it
sundae's them our mark of authority the
churches above the Bible and this
transference of Sabbath observance is
proof of that fact Catholic record a
person who violates the sanctity of
Sunday is to be punished as a heretic
john paul ii the EU must keep Sunday
says the Catholic Church is it directing
its attention against God's law and a
public domain yes honor Catholic Church
and trade unions from holy Alliance to a
forced Sunday observance
let me take it down into the bellows of
that 33 degree Lodge in Washington and
this is Albert Pike's room he is revered
as a god down there
everything is meticulous and there in
one on the windows it says Ordo AB Chao
order out of chaos we know that he
planned
Albert Pike planned three world wars in
a letter to Mancini
we shall unleash the nihilism the
atheist and we shall provoke a
formidable social Cataclysm which in its
horror will show clearly that to the
nation's the effect of absolute atheism
origin of savagery and the most bloody
turmoil then everywhere the citizens
obliged to defend themselves against the
minority of revolutionists will
exterminate those destroyers of
civilization and the multitude
disillusioned with Christianity will
receive the pure light through the
universal manifestation of the pure
doctrine of Lucifer the destruction of
Christianity and atheism both conquered
and exterminated at the same time here
is the gigantic mural in the United
Nations Security Council chamber and
there you see the fur necks rising out
of the ashes of a destroyed mankind are
we heading for the final clash two lines
the rule of law and the rule of the
Spirit this is now a definition from
legal dictionary the rule of law
according to law rule under law rule
according to a higher law the rule of
law is ambiguous term that can mean
different things in different contexts
in one context the terms means rule
according to the law no individual can
be ordered by the government to pay
civil damages or suffer criminal
punishment except in strict accordance
with the well established and clearly
defined laws and procedures and in the
second context the term means rule under
law now branch of
is above the law no public official may
act arbitrary or unilaterally outside
the law in a third context the term
means rule according to a higher law no
written law may be enforced by a
governor unless it conforms with certain
unwritten universal principles of
fairness morality and justice that
transcend human legal systems and
whenever that lawyers there must be
natural law and who wields natural law
Road Rome is the father and the mother
of natural law so she controls all law
she has the Mark of Cain and she says
the sign that I have this authority in
the world a god-given authority by the
way God permits that to bear that
responsibility is my mark of power and
that is that I changed the Sabbath to
Sunday now we've all seen this one
before but I just want to emphasize the
words rule of law let's hear the Sun for
institutions of freedom have lain
dormant the United Nations can offer
them new life these institutions play a
crucial role in our quest for a new
world order in order in which no nation
must surrender one iota of its own
sovereignty an order characterized by
the rule of law
rather than a resort to force everybody
must be subject to the what the rule of
law and the rule of law is subject to a
higher law and that law is wielded by
another authority behind the scenes
that's the legal definition the only one
who has ever laid claim to such a law is
the Roman Catholic Church and so
principalities and powers will have to
come and pay abeyance and so Obama will
go he was educated at Harvard if you
enter the Harvard Law School what is the
sign that you see there the sign of
Honor so here is the power to rule
Battlefield u.s. Americans face arrest
as war criminals on the army state law
Luke 21:26 men's hearts failing them for
fear and for looking after those things
which are coming on the earth for the
powers of heaven shall be shaken we are
heading for a final Cataclysm Senate
approves indefinite detention and
torture of Americans the terrifying
legislation that allows for Americans to
be arrested detained indefinitely
tortured and interrogated without charge
or trial passed through the Senate on
Thursday is it only applicable to
Americans or is the same thing happening
to other nations as well
do they use torture at Guantanamo Bay
yes or no is it a common known fact
do they use waterboarding and other
methods that we don't know well why
would the US clergy seek release of a
Senate report on post 9/11 torture if
there weren't torture and I want to
remind you of history it did the nations
in the past employed torture to those
who differed from their principles yes
or no did their Syrians do it yes and if
you go down the line did the Romans do
it yes and whenever it came to that
point once they reach a certain point
seventy times seven when probation
closes for them it is but normally these
nations became cruel and tortured people
are they showing pictures of people in
terrible states with chemicals on them
and all kinds of stuff like that who
supplies these things who makes it
possible for them to use it whoever
reduces I'm not interested in who is
using it I'm not accusing anyone I'm
saying that the children are evil of
children who rule over the children of
evil are using the methodologies which
the Bible describes throughout history
and we are at that point in history did
Obama sign a martial law executive
orders folks headed to happy hour last
Friday President Obama signed an
executive order that could potentially
given the part of Institutional martial
law even in a time of peace
Verizon forced to hand over telephone
data full court ruling are you being
watched
did Herod have a secret police force
that dragged any dissident to justice
which he was permitted to to bring about
absolutely are we at that same point in
history there's only one little
difference all those others serve this
type and they were all local but this
one is universal this is the last one
Huntington post denounces george w obama
it's beautiful there they have George
Bush and there you have a bomber
listening to your conversations and they
fuse the two brilliantly into george w
obama what does that picture say the
picture says it doesn't make any
difference whether it's the one ruling
or the other the same power behind the
sea
controls them both when Obama came to
power I screamed about all the
irregularities and terrible laws that
the previous one had made did he rescind
one no not one God's Word has given
warning of the impending danger let this
be unheeded and the Protestant world
will learn what the purposes of Rome
really are again I purposely choose
great controversy because we as a people
believe that this must be given to the
world only when it is too late to escape
the snare she's silently growing into
power her doctrines are exerting their
influence in legislative halls in the
churches and in the hearts of men
she's piling up her lofty and massive
structures in the secret recesses of
which her former persecutions will be
repeated I don't want to speak about
FEMA camps and this and that and the
other I don't care how many bunkers they
build or how many camps they both I know
one thing that the confrontation will be
between the powers of evil and the
powers of good and the only power that
can control the power of evil is Jesus
Christ himself and I am but a pawn in
this game that I can choose sides
I can choose sides and the rod can spare
me from the sword if he so wishes and
even if he doesn't he can resurrect me
but the other one can't stealthily and
unsuspectedly she is strengthening her
forces to further our own ends when the
time shall come for her to strike my
church is basking in the sunshine of her
acceptance
sitting in the sunshine moving a little
feets in ecstasy don't you know where
you are sitting don't you know it can
happen to you don't you know that you
can be grabbed at any moment all
that she desires is vantage-ground and
this was already being given a we shall
soon see and shall feel what the purpose
of the roman element is whoever shall
believe in obey the Word of God will
thereby encourage proach and persecution
make no bones about it
on the same day that President Obama
called for a new international order to
solve the challenges of our time
probability called for a new
international order both of them are
accustomed to interesting hand signs as
we see with both hands Time magazine the
new world pope meet the press' jesuit
priest and ignacio's press found that
joseph SEO said those who repel against
the church's authentic teaching or
rebelling against god rebelling against
which god revelation 19:15 and out of
the mouth out of his mouth goes a sharp
sword that with it he should smite the
nation's and he shall rule them with a
rod of iron and he treadeth the
winepress of the fierceness and wrath of
Almighty God 1 Corinthians 15:20 4 note
this text then cometh the end when he
shall have delivered up the kingdom to
God even the father when he shall have
put down all rule and all authority and
all power they are permitted to rule
they have been granted by God the Mark
of Cain they can exercise their power to
a limit which God sets and when that
limit comes he ends it he's done it
through history we've looked at it and
we
at the point when the same principles
that applied to the close of probation
in all the other kingdoms are coming to
a head in our time if people do not want
to see it that's their business but it
is my duty my duty to make them aware of
the danger that they are in and I appeal
to my church and I appeal to the world
to look at the Protestant heritage and
to look at what we taught as a church
and to warn the people of the coming
danger rather than cuddling up to that
it is now time to make a decision and
may God help us to make the right one
amen
[Music]
[Applause]